[Music]
on this Wednesday night chaos confusion
and cancellations the Americans
system-wide outage that grounded
thousands of flights and Stranded
millions of Travelers we've been delayed
three times how vulnerable is Canada to
something similar California gets a
brief break the cleanup but the warning
of what's on the way
a critical Court ruling on indigenous
lobster fishing rights oh it means a lot
The Next Step First Nations could take
plus escaping Afghanistan to start over
in Canada
two girls celebrate the freedom and
Independence they thought was impossible
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with the impact of a
system-wide failure in the U.S causing
thousands of flight delays and
cancellations a computer system that
alerts Pilots to potential hazards went
down overnight and the Federal Aviation
Administration grounded nearly all
planes across the U.S the system is
working again but the ripple effect has
led to a huge backlog of flights
President Joe Biden has ordered a full
investigation though the White House
says there's no evidence of a Cyber
attack more than 9 000 flights within
two or out of the U.S are delayed at
least 1300 canceled among the hardest
hit is Baltimore Washington Airport
nearly half of all arrivals and
departures there are delayed all of this
also had an effect on cross-border
travel to and from Canada we'll get to
that in just a moment but we begin with
Jackson prosco on what went wrong
departure boards tell the story of a day
of travel chaos this says cancel okay
you're just finding that out now yes
literally just now for almost two hours
nearly all commercial air traffic in and
into the U.S was grounded by a computer
failure this morning when we woke up we
had the news so we thought we're just
going to rent a car and not fly by the
time the system came back online it was
clear travel plans for Millions were
scuttled with thousands of flights
either delayed or canceled Charlie and
Joan Brown's overnight trip was up in
the air they were not we were completely
surprised and I have a flight out
tomorrow at 9 00 A.M
do you think things will be back to
normal by then that's already they're
saying that's canceled the headaches
weren't limited to American airspace
many U.S bound flights from Canada were
delayed or canceled as well frustration
quickly spilled over the Border confused
yes stressed out yet
the culprit was a crash of a computer
system used by the U.S Federal Aviation
Administration known as notice to air
missions or notam notam gives Pilots
critical safety information about U.S
airport and airspace operations details
they need before takeoff the critical
system like this has a lot of redundancy
built into it with backups so we need to
understand why with all of that
redundancy it still Rose to the level
that there had to be a ground stop
Americans and Canadians have faced
plenty of travel frustration in the last
few weeks with bad weather and Airline
computer problems stranding thousands
over the holidays we've had a lot of
airport issues this season officials
insist there's no indication of a Cyber
attack or sabotage in Wednesday's
incident but there will be an
investigation into the largest ground
stop of U.S air traffic since September
11 2001. even with the FAA systems fully
restored the Ripple effects are expected
to last for several days perhaps until
the weekend it's going to take time for
the airlines to get their schedules back
on track and their planes properly
positioned Jackson prosco Global News
Arlington Virginia
there is more information on the
situation here in Canada and gaviola is
with me from Toronto and the no temp
system that alerts Pilots to potential
hazards failed here in Canada today too
what can you tell us about that
yeah navcan tells me that we saw a brief
outage to new entries into our notam
system today it started at 10 20 a.m
eastern time it lasted about three hours
but there were mitigations put in place
so that operations could continue and
there will be an investigation to try
and figure out what the root cause of
that was although it's not believed to
be related to what happened in the U.S
and a lot of people may be wondering why
was the impact So Different Here in
Canada there are a lot of factors to
consider including the fact that we've
had upgrades to our systems so what
we're dealing with here is systems that
are not as Antiquated as what they have
in the U.S and there's also the fact
that Canadian airspace is a lot less
complicated than what they have South of
the Border in terms of the sheer number
of flights but also we have less major
International hubs Donna all right and
there's already been so much disruption
and to airline travel recently is it
likely to get any better in 2023
I'm afraid I don't have great news on
that front and air Travelers should
probably pack a lot of patience what we
know is that a lot of workers have left
the industry and now what we're dealing
with is labor shortages you can see that
at airports you can see it on Airlines
and also a lot of those new recruits are
still being onboarded and trained so
what that means is it's likely to have
an exacerbating effect when there are
major weather related events or major
events like we saw South of the Border
Donna all right and gaviola in Toronto
thank you
in California there's a brief break in
the rain but millions of people are
bracing for what's coming next weeks of
rain have left entire subdivisions
submerged more than half of California's
58 Counties have been declared disaster
areas even a few inches of water can do
a lot of damage leaving ankle deep muddy
water as people salvage what they can
from their homes Heather York's West
reports on the cleanup and the new round
of brutal storms on the way
entire communities are submerged in
California the latest in a series of
powerful storms came on so quickly for
some their only Escape was by air I told
my wife we better get ready and we
started packing and getting ready and we
were looking out the window and then we
saw the bridge go and when that bridge
went there's no way out
with a break in the forecast Wednesday
residents of Southern California began
to clean up while thunderstorms led a
new atmospheric River into the northern
part of the state this is the Bay Area
San Francisco Bay Area
we're getting another storm right now
the mountainous Sierra County saw
another 15 centimeters of snow snowpack
in the high mountains is 200 to 300
percent above April first averages so
there's going to be a delayed effect as
well going into the spring of snowmelt
that's uh going to be after managed as
well
but for now these storm systems aren't
finished yet Southern California is
expected to see more wet weather
starting this weekend the state's
Governor warning it will be a difficult
week ahead we expect a minimum three
more of these atmospheric rivers and
different shapes and forms depending on
different parts of the state at least 17
people have been killed while the search
continues for five-year-old Kyle Doane
who was Swept Away Monday as Rescuers
tried to pull him and his mother from
raging flood waters the loss of life and
property so far has been devastating we
lost our home and all of our like
belongings that we had the extreme
weather a product of climate change that
only seems to be getting worse Heather
York's West Global News
aids to the American President Joe Biden
have discovered more classified
documents they were found in a location
separate from the Washington office he
used after leaving the Obama
Administration it's unclear exactly
where they were though how many there
are and what level of classification
they are nor do we know when they were
discovered Biden says he is fully
cooperating with the justice department
review Biden's personal lawyers revealed
earlier this week they discovered about
10 files some marked Top Secret in a
locked Closet in his Washington Office
of the think tank the Penn Biden Center
U.S federal law prohibits knowingly
removing classified information and
retaining it in an unauthorized location
Canada's relationship with Mexico was
top of mind for prime minister Justin
Trudeau today he met with his Mexican
counterpart at the North American
leaders Summit Mackenzie gray breaks
down what they talked about and Canada's
takeaways at the so-called Three Amigos
meeting in Mexico City
this final day in Mexico Justin Trudeau
turned his attention to the other amigo
Mexican president Andreas Manuel Lopez
obrador and the Prime Minister focusing
on trade we will continue to talk about
how we can even further
increase our economic partnership and
finding common ground on opposing
protectionists by America policies from
U.S President Joe Biden that's their
common interest they want to buy North
American pose and there have been
positive developments there but the
Mexicans have their own protection as
rules with Lopez obrador nationalizing
several Mexican energy companies let's
draw the iron of Canadian firms who do
business in Mexico
but the president told Trudeau he's
willing to work to solve the issue they
want to portray themselves both as
allies of the broader North American
project and not caught up in Petty
discussions about one industrial sector
or another but it's a request from the
other Amigo that's shown minor cracks in
North American Unity
shooter turning down Joe Biden's ass to
have Canada lead a security force in
troubled Haiti Canada today backing up
its support for local police by
airlifting haitian-purchased armored
vehicles to Port-au-Prince but when
pushed on Biden's proposal shooter left
the door open to acquiescing to the
Americans preparing various scenarios if
it does start to get worse but we also
know that right now
what is effective is empowerment of the
Haitian National Police to solve the
situation themselves Justin Trudeau
flies back to Canada tonight wrapping up
his three-day trip to Mexico and will
continue meeting with world leaders
tomorrow Donna when the Japanese prime
minister is set to visit Parliament Hill
all right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you the situation in Haiti has unraveled
even further the terms of the last 10
Senators who were remaining in office
expired last night and that's left a
political vacuum the Caribbean nation is
now without a single democratically
elected government official organized
crime groups have been running virtually
unchecked since the summer of 2021 when
the former president was assassinated
two-thirds of Haiti's Capital
Port-au-Prince is now estimated to be
under the control of Warring gangs and a
record 4.7 million people are said to be
facing acute hunger prime minister Ariel
Ari is still there but he was never
elected and is seen by most Haitians as
illegitimate
Ukraine has released footage of what it
says are Russian troops Under Fire in
the Eastern town of solidar the video
appears to refute Russian claims it took
control of the small salt mining town
yesterday Ukraine says the fighting is
intensifying with forces firing
howitzers at Russian positions so ladar
is key to accessing the nearby city of
bakmut which has held out for months
against the Russians the area is in
Donetsk one of the four regions Russia
illegally annexed last year in his
latest address Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski mocked Russia for
suggesting the fighting had stopped
off-duty police officers are being
praised for quickly apprehending an
armed attacker at a Paris train station
during the early morning rush hour at
gardenor investigators say six people
including a police officer were injured
when a man came after them with a metal
hook within a minute police say the
officers returning from their night
shift shot and arrested the suspect he's
in the hospital in a criminal
investigation is underway it happened at
one of the busiest train stations in
France
in the Afghan capital a suicide bomb
attack outside the foreign Ministry has
caused heavy casualties Kabul police say
at least five civilians were killed
Taliban officials put the death toll as
high as 20. the local offshoot of the
Islamic State group has claimed it
carried out the attack
lobster fishing rights for indigenous
people coming up a new ruling from a
Nova Scotia judge and what it could mean
Plus
[Music]
the Young piano Prodigy who's never had
a music lesson
there's a development in the ongoing
conflict over indigenous fishing rights
in Nova Scotia a Provincial Court Judge
has ruled in favor of three migma
fishermen accused of illegally catching
Lobster that has First Nations
Harvesters hopeful there's a new level
of respect for their treaty rights and
optimistic the tense sometimes violent
confrontations with some commercial
fishermen will end Ross Lord explains
frightening confrontations and
devastating property damage seen in 2020
have now given way to court action on
Monday a Nova Scotia Court acquitted
migma Harvester James Nevin and two
others of charges they violated the
Fisheries act well it means a lot it
means a lot to all migma people the men
are from the sabagan agony First Nation
their lawyer argued they were simply
exercising Court protected treaty rights
to a moderate livelihood rights that
exempt them from government regulations
in acquitting the men Provincial Court
Judge Timothy Landry said in order for
me to know that the fishermen possess
fish that were caught contrary to the
Fisheries act I have to know they don't
have the authority to fish in any other
fashion which I don't Nevin says the
ruling eases his emotional distress you
know I sank into
um like a type of depression thinking
about this case you know consistently
and
but I mean
it's a good way to start off the uh the
New Year by you know everything being
dismissed the lack of evidence suggests
DFO enforcement was ineffective but the
Fisher's defense lawyer considers the
ruling a turning point I think it's
going to have a domino effect plus I'm
going to start an action against
Department of fishies I'm on behalf of
my clients it seems some First Nations
are going along with the government out
of 35 in Atlanta Canada and gas Bay
Quebec DFO says it's reached interim
understandings allowing eight First
Nations to fish and sell their catch
during the DFO established commercial
Seasons without increasing overall
fishing effort
commercial Fishers say out of season
Lobster Landings could deplete stalks
indigenous Fishers say that's impossible
because they have smaller boats and far
fewer traps with consensus still Out Of
Reach a commercial fishing group
suggests the courts are indeed a more
practical Resort I guess there's a
potential that subang Navy and ufca
would both like to see this case
resolved in the Supreme Court that would
be one one point of agreement similar
cases are scheduled to be heard in
coming weeks providing either more
clarity or complication
Ross Lord Global News shubinacity Nova
Scotia
Ontario Premier Doug Ford has confirmed
his government will fight a court
decision to certify a class-action
lawsuit that relates to covid-19 deaths
in Ontario's Long-Term Care Homes
thousands of residents died as a result
of the virus especially in the early
stages of the pandemic the suit claims
The Province was grossly negligent in
failing to prevent those fatalities Ford
admits the virus presented challenges
but says it was the same around the
world and he says Ontario performed
better than most other places
[Music]
piano Prodigy ahead the young boy who
was stunning everyone with his talent
[Music]
[Music]
that is eleven-year-old Jude Kofi a
self-taught Pianist who plays like he's
had years of lessons Jude who has autism
stunned his family when he started
playing his dad's old keyboard in the
basement he plays by ear he's never had
a lesson I was inspired I was inspired
by God I never stopped always on and on
and on and on yeah
three hours a day a piano tuner who
describes Jude as a Mozart level Talent
bought him a grand piano as a surprise
and now he's learning to read music
Jude's father originally from Ghana says
he hoped to make a career of Music
himself but ended up working two jobs to
support his family in the U.S and back
in Ghana his son looks set to follow his
dream
I love that smile the music world is
mourning a loss today Jeff Beck often
described as one of the greatest
guitarists of all time has died
he played with The Yardbirds and the
Jeff Beck Group and worked with the
likes of Rod Stewart Beck was an
innovator who pioneered distinct and
distorted guitar sounds heard in many
music genres today from Jazz to heavy
metal his fingers and thumbs were
insured for nine million dollars back
won eight Grammys he was inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame twice he
died on Tuesday after Contracting
bacterial meningitis he was 78 years old
Girl Guides of Canada has renamed the
brownies the program for girls aged
seven and eight will now be called
Embers the organization says it made the
change to create more inclusive spaces
where racialized girls can feel welcome
and proud after an online vote Embers
was chosen over the second place name
comets
leading a new life next to teenagers
from Afghanistan making the most of
their new opportunity in Canada
[Music]
going to the mall or having a part-time
job or things most Canadian teenagers
take for granted but for new Canadians
who have fled oppressive or war-torn
regimes simple things like that are
exceptional six living in Afghanistan
have faced Decades of religious
persecution the majority of them fleeing
the country some have come to Canada as
refugees and as need through garcha
reports they're making the most of their
Newfound freedom
standing core is in the orange there
13 year old gender and 15 year old
jaspal Khalsa can't help but giggle
watching videos of themselves in 2015
what they consider a happy time having
just fled Afghanistan for India where
they had become refugees what do you
think when you see this it's so like
flashback they were among hundreds of
six who were given an ultimatum
Afghanistan either convert to Islam or
accept death after the second chance in
my life like God gifted me a second
chance Paul came to Canada this past
spring the grade 10 student works
part-time at a local restaurant and
hopes to become a nurse my mother tagged
me you are you are very lucky to you you
have you live in planet or no
yeah you have very beautiful future in
Canada chander has been here since 2019.
the grade 8 student says she loves
shopping a very different experience
from Afghanistan where she could hardly
leave her home
my father and brother they go to
alternate and they call us and show us
what you want to buy
now she dreams of becoming a chef
when I first met these girls they were
hiding behind their moms and their moms
were hiding behind their husband BC
resident hamrit Baines traveled to India
where she spent months helping families
as they awaited private sponsorship to
this country Baines was inspired by
former Alberta cabinet minister manmit
Buller in 2015 Fuller learned the plight
of persecuted Hindu and Sikh families in
Afghanistan who had tried for years to
come to Canada he worked tirelessly to
help them through his passion for
selfless service he treated them as his
family I I know he had said like
if I have to give everything I have I
will for these families but he would
never see the impact of his efforts just
six months after starting Buller died
while trying to help a driver in
distress I and my family have no choice
but to continue this work because it's
so tied closely to the man that we love
Fuller's sister thurjinder helped create
the foundation in his name she says
they've helped bring more than 200
Afghans to Canada and committed to
supporting at least 500 more it's the
next generation of people that hopefully
will see that they have a life here in
Canada because someone halfway around
the world started to think about how can
I help them one message for that
otherwise if so want anything you can do
anything
generational change they hope will
continue to be paid forward
Global News Delta BC
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is morant's curve in Banff
National Park where the CP rail line
runs along the Bow River a beautiful
spot we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]